this is bismillah Salam alaikum peace be
with you thank you for tuning in to the
Deen show if you didn't know already
peace be unto you is a greeting of all
the prophets including the mighty
messenger the one that is so beloved to
our hearts no Muslim is a Muslim unless
he believes in Jesus Christ peace be
upon him we are not the Antichrist but
if we don't believe in Jesus we cannot
be Muslim Muslim is simply one who
surrenders and submits to the one God
and we are going to be talking about
Jesus peace be upon him in this episode
and we're going to be giving me some
some of the top 5 reasons according to
dr. Lawrence Brown on why Jesus peace be
upon him is not God never said or
claimed to be God nor the begotten Son
of God dr. Lawrence Brown has a PhD in
religious studies he has a DD Doctor of
Divinity he was a former atheist who
tried to be very hard to be a Christian
it just didn't fit it didn't make sense
this Trinity and all the other all the
other factors that makes one a Christian
nowadays it just didn't make sense and
he became a Muslim and he's here on the
Deen show to give us his top 5 when we
come back sit tight don't go nowhere
Salam alaikum peace be with you dr.
Lawrence around back on the Deen show
how was your trip over here long long
long but not as long as we didn't have
jet airplanes yeah okay thank you for
finding the time to be with us here on
the Deen show we're gonna like to have
you back so we can continue talking
about Jesus who is so beloved to our
hearts in this week's episode we're
going to be talking about some of your
top 5 reasons why Jesus peace be upon
him is not the begotten Son of God is
that correct that's correct and then
we'll do future episodes inshallah God
willing about some of these very other
important topics about Jesus so let's
start off here let's start off with you
know before I go on hold on I just want
to I want to make a note that you know I
know this might be a little bit
sensitive to some people and we're not
trying to hurt nobody's feelings we just
want to present a different proposition
one that we believe is the truth so I
just wanted to make that that that note
before we continue on yeah I don't know
if you wanted to add some today yeah I
guess I think I would and
is that we as Muslims we Revere Jesus
Christ we we follow his teachings but
the point here is that you do not draw
closer to a person you do not draw
closer to God by exceeding exceeding the
reality okay what do I mean by that what
I mean is that Jesus Christ called
himself the son of man others called him
the son of God okay now if he is
identifying himself as a man you do not
you are not going to endear yourself to
the Prophet by making him out to be more
than what he actually was looking good
analogy is is like this I was present
once where a family member was
celebrating a birthday they had asked
for a wallet okay so just you know his
wife you know his wife what can I get
you this year dear said I would like a
wallet but I would like it this way and
back way you know how I mean a wallet
for us is like a purse for a woman I
mean we want it we wanted our particular
way yes we know what we like but she had
found something that she liked better
right and he said I'm on it this way you
know a bifold not a trifold black not
brown with a you know this is you know
this number of pockets and for the
credit cards and so on and so forth
he knew exactly what he wanted but she
went she saw what she liked she liked
this better and that's what she bought
for him
okay cost more money it was a lot more
fancy she got it from New York City
instead of from you know the little town
where they lived and so on and so forth
but in the end there wasn't what he
asked for okay
despite the despite the fact that she
had gone out of her way to get you know
something far far better than what she
thought he wanted he had no use for it
he got upset when he saw it because he
said I told you I don't want it like
this I don't care if it costs five times
more than what I asked for it could cost
ten times more it's not what I wanted
it's not what okay now it's the same
same way in
with religion okay if the Prophet if the
Prophet is saying I'm a man I'm not I'm
not the Son of God and yet you elevate
him them status to the Son of God or you
make him divine in your own mind this is
not going to win you points and in the
Hereafter
so so the point is we are focusing upon
what Jesus Christ actually said who he
really said he was and and that suffices
for us because that is what God sufficed
to send us in his message now that is a
very important point and that's out of
the love for our brothers in humanity we
don't want all their good deeds to go to
waste and setting up a partner giving
those divine rights other to God or
setting up a co-equal partner to God
this can land you in the Hellfire
forever forever so and sometimes you got
to keep your love in check
yeah sometimes you got to keep your love
in check you know a strong man hugging
his wife I mean if he really loves her
too much I mean he can you know I love
you so much
crunch-crunch-crunch you know I mean you
can hurt a person yeah you can hurt a
person in the same way when it comes to
religion you can hurt yourself by
exceeding the boundaries of what is
accepted by God yes yes yes definitely
and that's why we're here so let's go
dr. Lawrence Brown has a DD doctor in
divinity PhD in religious studies here
I'm the Dean show to give us his top
five reasons why Jesus is not the
begotten Son of God number five talk to
me okay number five if you ask most
Christians if you believe in this
doctrine to begin with you know do you
believe that Jesus Christ was begotten
not made most of them on the surface
will say yeah well okay that's part of
my religion yes but do you believe it
most will start to backpedal if you go
look it up and Merriam Webster's
Dictionary the gotten the definition is
to procreate as the father it implies
the carnal element of sex okay now this
this means that I mean you're actually
having to challenge the person say are
you saying that you actually believe
that God has sex with Mary the mother of
Jesus is that what you are saying when
you say begotten not made
I mean 99.9% they'll say no no of course
not I mean they will realize the
absurdity of that claim the the
blasphemy of that claim and so they will
start to back down and you'll say well
if if this is what begotten means and
you're admitting that you don't believe
that that it involves procreation as the
father as the definition of the word
then why do you believe in it and from
there you will find people will begin to
soften their stance so that's number
five that's the number five reason
number five we're going to continue move
on time is short we don't got but only a
little bit of time we're gonna cover all
these things we're gonna move on to
number four of dr. Lawrence Brown top
five reasons why Jesus is not - begotten
Son of God number four give it to us
number four it is an evolved doctrine
okay it was a doctrine that was derived
at the Council of Nicaea in the year 325
it was later placed into the astana
chien Creed canarios who is the patriot
patriarch of Constantinople when he
heard the council of nicaea a statement
in this regard he actually pronounced it
the words of a drunken man the
Athanasian Creed in part it reads quote
God from God light from light true God
from True God begotten not made one in
being with the father if you really sit
down and have a heart-to-heart
conversation with yourself you might
find yourself agreeing with Gennady as'
and saying these were the words of a
drunken man no we don't like to be
offensive and saying this sounds you
know I mean this the sounds like the
ramblings of a drunken man but what we
are saying is that for somebody who sits
down and just analyzes these words with
an open heart and an open mind in terms
of whether they really make sense to him
a vast majority of mankind are going to
say no no I you know I can't accept that
it just doesn't make sense
we went from number five to number four
of the top five reasons why Jesus peace
be upon him who is beloved to our hearts
my team
your God never claimed to be God never
said he was God is not God why he's not
God with dr. Lawrence brow we right back
with number three do not go anywhere I
don't say the people I used to be a
Christian I still carry the values and
principles of loving Jesus Christ
perhaps we may be more than evil so I
think I got the best out of Christianity
by becoming Muslim without drinking a
sip of all this is the same thing it's
not an obstacle it's not something to
cause people to get completely desperate
and start stopping living their lives no
it should be a motivation it's only one
life that you're going to be living so
you better do it for a lot China Matata
back here on the Dean show and we're
giving you the top five reasons dr.
Brown's top five reasons why Jesus peace
be upon him is not the begotten Son of
God we went for five four let's go to
number three okay take it away number
three in Psalms 2:7 David is is spoken
about in these terms quote the Lord has
said to me you are my son today I have
begotten you
are we talking about Jesus Christ no
talking about David Psalms 2:7 okay so
the point is now the doctrine have
begotten not made is not just that Jesus
Christ was allegedly begotten not made
no it's that Jesus Christ was the only
begotten Son of God begotten and not
made but the only one and yet here we
find in the same book the Bible in
Psalms chapter 2 verse 7 we find that it
states clearly quote the Lord has said
to me you are my son today I have
begotten you you are my son today I have
begotten you how can you have Jesus
Christ being the only begotten Son of
God
when you have David many many many
generations before allegedly having been
told you are my son today I have
begotten you so is it safe to say that
if you look deeper into the Bible that
the Bible has sons by the tongues I've
heard this said before is this true yeah
actually I wasn't even going to go into
that but you find many passages speaking
of the sons of God and and the children
of God and so on
so yes the sons of God was actually a
metaphorical term not a literal term it
didn't mean literally a son of God it
was it was a metaphor in fact all of the
Jews considered themselves children of
God sons and daughters of God that was
the status they conceived for themselves
it was a metaphorical issue
hold on hold on but they say no for
Jesus it's a capital S what do you got
to say what I have to say is that there
is nothing to support that the the
manuscripts from which the Bible are is
translated both in the Hebrew in the
Aramaic and in the Greek there was no
capitalization of any of these whenever
you read the Bible and you see any
letter capitalized even the letters at
the beginning of a sentence those
letters were not capitalized in the
manuscripts from which the Bible was
translated the Bible is translated from
a body of manuscripts right now we have
five thousand four hundred manuscripts
none of them have capitalization so the
capitalization is something that people
have put in and in some cases they put
it in as a device to emphasize what they
wanted to emphasize but that is not
being faithful to the scripture not
being faithful at all okay so we got to
be sincere and we got to really want to
do God's will we can't just do things
and just make it fit because it fits our
desires well you remember how we are
talking in a previous session about how
a lot of people get turned off to
religion because they see people playing
with religion this is one of the ways in
which people play with religion they try
to make it to be more or less than what
they want it to be they add what is not
there or they take away what is there
and this is one of those cases where
they are adding something that is not
there mainly namely capitalization or
special usage of particular words you're
talking about capitalization we've
talked about five four three let's go to
two a number two reason for why Jesus
Christ is not the begotten son of God in
a begotten not made sense is that in the
Bible the word that is translated to
only begotten mahogany's mo n o G en es
this is the word that is translated to
only be God we're on number two now
we're on number two so you get we went
from five four three and now this is the
number two
reason why Jesus peace be upon him is
not God and this is relating to what we
were just talking about which is why I'm
slipping in there you know the this word
mahogany's is found 9 times in the Bible
okay three times it's found in Luke
you'll find it in 712 842 and 938 okay
in all three of those passages it does
not speak of Jesus Christ is speaking of
other individuals okay now this is the
same word when you find it in John it
identifies Jesus Christ has only
begotten but when this same word is used
in Luke regarding other individuals
guess what it's not translated only
begotten now why is that again this is
we were just talking about how people
kind of add what they want or take away
what they what they don't want this is
this is an example where there's an
inconsistency in how the word is
translated you have to ask yourself why
this word is found like I said nine
times in the Bible three times in Luke
you know all three of those times
it speaks of individuals other than
Jesus Christ and it does not identify
them as only begotten five times it's
found in John John four times in the
Gospel of John one time in the Epistle
of John okay in the First Epistle of
John in those five instances it speaks
of Jesus Christ as only begotten okay
the ninth time that's the kicker Hebrews
11:17 in Hebrews 11:17 what is that what
is the word applied to the word is fly
to Isaac Isaac is monogamy's now why is
that important the reason that's
important is because Ishmael was born 14
years before Isaac okay
Abraham his first son was Ishmael when
Isaac was born Ishmael was 14 years old
how could either be the only begotten
son of Abraham when Ishmael was born 14
years before it's not possible not
possible okay and if you if you question
if you say okay well Ishmael wasn't
really Abraham's son right some people
say that some people
say okay Abraham second wife was wasn't
really a wife you have to just go back
to the Bible if you read the Bible it
says that Sarah gave Hagar to Abraham as
a wife polygamy was permitted at that
time it was allowed polygamy was the
standard at the time that's why you find
David that's why you find Solomon with
so many wives polygamy was allowed okay
and and if you question whether he was
the son just read Genesis 1611 read
genesis 16:15 17 7 17 23 and 17 25 and
there are more passages why do you read
those passages because in those passages
God recognized Isaac excused God God
recognized Ishmael as Abraham's son okay
so as I said if God is recognizing
Ishmael as Abraham's son 14 years before
Isaac then how can i zyk be the only
begotten son and yet that is the word to
identify him monogamy's so what we're
finding is that word mahogany's in Luke
in three places when it's applied to
other individuals it's mistranslated in
Hebrews 11:17 when is talking about
Isaac it simply cannot be only begotten
because he was not the only begotten son
of Abraham now for the layman that was
number 2 from 5 for to go to number 1
for the layman he doesn't know much of
these passages he doesn't know much of
the Bible he believes in God he knows
this doesn't make sense
to bring it home I mean what does
someone and I'm sure you've had a lot of
discourse and dialogue with people who
believe this but have you ever asked
them what do you mean when you say God
had a son because we know that you know
cats have kittens cows have calves you
know what does God if you had a son is
that a baby God is it a number two God
how do they make sense of it what are
they actually saying you know here's
where the personal religion comes in
because people just explained it in
different ways I think if most people
are honest with themselves they don't
really they don't really understand the
concept because you have to remember in
the Trinity in the concept of the
Trinity the Father
the Holy Spirit the teaching is not just
that these three individuals exist but
that they are co-equal Co eternal and
consubstantial okay that means that they
are okay in saying that they are Co
eternal all three of them are eternal
and yet if you're saying this is the
father
and this is the son how can a son be
eternal if it comes from the father this
is this is an early argument but
Unitarian priest areas who basically
said if you're going to call in the son
you can't call him eternal because the
son comes from the father okay
how can they be consubstantial of the
same substance and how you know how can
they be co-equal when one is printed to
the other Jesus Christ was praying to
God so how can you say these two are
equal I mean if you have the same powers
if you have godly powers you don't need
to pray to anybody because what is the
purpose of Prayer the purpose of prayer
is to ask God to do something for you
and if you have these powers yourself
you don't need to ask God to do
something for you just famine it's done
okay so when you really get into it most
people most people just even if they
don't admit it with their words at least
when they go home and think about it
they realize you have something like
something doesn't quite fit you got to
be sincere you got to be sincere sincere
with yourself sincere with the one who
knows the hearts the crater that
Heaven's in air we'll be right back with
number one reason why Jesus peace be
upon him is not the begotten Son of God
right back you will not feel a woman do
not kill a child doing that
you know going to different digital
Buddhism in Division forms of
Christianity I even ran into people from
the Nation of Islam feeling hey man you
will not feel an animal you will not cut
a tree down do not tell me through water
do not burn their homes
back here on the D show dr. Lawrence
Brown dd doctor and divinity PhD in
religious studies trying very hard to be
a Christian you went from atheism to
Christianity to Islam people go to the
Deen show calm to see the other shows
and to see how you accepted the world's
fastest growing way of life in the world
today gets most misunderstood is the way
of life of all the messengers of God
Islam dat complete and total submission
acquiring peace by submitting your self
entirely to the one God this is Islam
and a Muslim is one who does the action
of Islam now tell us we went from five
four three two and give us the number
one and the reason why Jesus peace be
upon him that mighty messenger of God
was not never claimed to me never said
never was the begotten Son of God
talk to us okay well I'd ask for a
drumroll but lacking one the number one
reason is don't listen to me don't
listen to him we were just talking about
how you were saying make it simple
a lot of people you know when they hear
the whole explanation they just want it
made simple for them it's all make it
simple for you don't listen to any of us
you know who you should listen to if
you're a Christian listen to your Bible
that's all I ask you to do listen to
your Bible why because the Revised
Standard Version the New Revised
Standard Version the New International
Version the good news Bible the new
English Bible the Jerusalem Bible and
many others have recognized the force of
the arguments that I have given today
and they have removed this from their
own Bibles if you go to read those
Bibles and the New Revised Standard
Version the New International Version
are the largest selling Bibles and and
and the most the most scholastic Bibles
in the history of mankind and they have
removed this from their text because
they realize it is illegitimate so like
I said if you're Christian you don't
need to trust me trust your own Bible
and you will find that the biblical
scholars themselves have removed this
from the biblical text yet in those
Bibles are quoted and many others it no
longer says begotten not made
that no longer says only begotten son
that has been removed they recognize
that it's not valid you should recognize
it's not valid also the person says no
no no no I grew up on the King James
Version that's all I go by what he got
to say King James Version was written in
1611 okay that's four hundred that's
four hundred years old now I understand
you might like the way it's written but
there were many texts many biblical
texts discovered after that the most
that the earliest biblical texts ever
discovered with a codex Vaticanus and
the codex Sinaiticus and those were
discovered after the King James Version
was written so that is new information
not only new information those are the
earliest biblical manuscripts that that
the Bible can be translated from and
that gives us the most reliable source
for information for the Bible and that
information was missing when the new
king of when the King James Version was
translated so if you want if you want
the best information the most the most
accurate translation of the Bible you
have to go to a Bible that was was
agreed upon by ecumenical council
meeting it was agreed upon by a
coalition of different Christian
Christian groups and that is the New
Revised Standard Version we only have a
minute left
you still love Jesus you're not a
Christian anymore
and people who see our other show that
we did comparing how Muslims really
follow Christ more than the modern day
Christians today and how he worship his
mannerisms and all these other details
tell us now for the person who really
has an attachment to Jesus you just
broke it down five top reasons why he's
not the begotten son of God
not God none of these things so who was
he briefly described and where does the
person go from here no quite simply
Jesus Christ was exactly what he said he
was he was a man he was a prophet
bearing revelation from God he was sent
to the lost sheep of the house of Israel
he
was he was there to bring them back from
their deviation and provide a revelation
which would keep people upon the correct
path but I tell you what I was just
talking with the taxi driver the other
day we were driving down a long road and
we were having just this discussion he
was Catholic I'm Muslim and I said you
know what it's like it's like this road
I said this is the path the Jews were on
this path the Christians were on this
path and the Muslims are at the end of
this path the Jews they pulled over and
parked with Moses and they said no they
won't they won't accept Jesus Christ
they won't accept John the Baptist okay
so they they just pulled over early in
parked that's where they stopped the
Christians continued on with John the
Baptist and with Jesus Christ and they
stopped there and they said this
suffices for us and they pulled over and
they stopped okay and they were happy
with their position but if you want to
get to the end of the road you have to
go with the final predicted Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him so it's not
it's not a question necessarily of being
upon the wrong path sometimes sometimes
even if you're on the right path it's a
question of taking it all the way to the
end so if you if you truly love Jesus
you will believe in him as as you taught
us to believe in him and one of the
things that he taught was that there was
a final prophet coming we can talk about
that in a later session if you love
Jesus you will look for that final
prophet you will pray to God to guide
you to the religion of truth and when
you find that prophet and final prophet
you will accept him and the revelation
with which it came we as Muslims believe
that is Muhammad the revelation is the
Holy Quran and that is why we have
accepted Islam people who want to
continue on further maybe dialoguing
talking with you how could they get a
hold of you and also to read some of
your books that you discussed is more in
detail why my books are on my websites
along with my articles my conversion
story basically more than you would want
to know about me
my websites are level truth com le ve el
truth TR u th comm and eight scroll com
8 e IG h th scroll su ro ll calm thank
you very much and they God Almighty the
creator Allah reward you for being with
us once again thank you I mean and
that's it for another episode
of the Deen show that was the top five
reasons why Jesus peace be upon him
cannot be never was the begotten son of
God God doesn't have sons or daughters
God doesn't walk the earth
you can't take his picture doesn't have
an area code he's the creator of all
that exists he's one and alone worthy of
worship and Jesus worship the one God
Moses did Abraham and the last and final
messenger peace be upon him the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him we don't
worship Muhammad we just follow his way
the same way you were to follow Jesus
and Moses they were teachers teaching us
how to submit how to worship how to
become the best human being that you can
become and that's not by following your
desires that's by doing God's will and
that's Islam peace acquired by
submitting to the one God and a Muslim
is deaf one who does this action we'll
see you next time here indeed show until
then peace be unto you
you